so have you guys seen the brand new
Tesla truck I dig the truck to me I've
been doing hard on Tesla dig the trucks
that concept though they're not gonna
actually know they're doing it right now
much is it 39,000 starting off that's
yeah
starting off 39 you don't know you don't
own the first-generation tesla Harmer
class
yeah and it has armored glass they
revealed this truck over the weekend and
Elon Musk was there and told the speaker
to throw it was like some sort of like
ball at the window to show something
like that something round and heart must
be bulletproof
it's called their new armored glass and
it's supposed to be super resilient so
the speaker says are you sure do you
want me to throw this and Elon says yes
so this is a promise you can't get out
of it and you can't like what what about
when you're no rap no no that's not the
problem here's the problem good play
this yeah you old thoughts yeah leave
this yeah well you know muss goes off he
barely threw it he goes well then go
through okay I think it looks sweet it's
just embarrassing for him but also this
was the concept so it's like no one told
him that the windows aren't bulletproof
yet like did you think oh they're not
yeah no this is just it's a [ __ ] demo
bro we're gonna power through the
goddamn windows because that was a very
lame throw yeah yes that was a toss I
dig the truck though but yeah that's the
new Tesla truck yeah
people wanna see whether you would hate
but can I see you guys driving and stuff
that thing is amazing oh yeah that might
be my next car nothing
no no why it's not man certain things
are for you but I want it's not for
boomers but I like no but I want it oh I
love this this is my boy Miro go down
what's the name
de Muro Doug de Muro gives the best car
breakdowns out of anything any car you
have see if he's done it he he's a super
nerd but damn is he good at it yeah I
feel like this is for boomers it looks
sweet I will buy that Tesla it's 40
grand I will buy one when are they
available Oh buy one right now what I
think it's already on pre-order I'm not
sure yeah that's the gonna come home and
be deliver looks like it yeah it's just
super clean oh it's got a weird steering
well now I won't be buying that I think
that's the concept Cyril right
definitely not for me
yeah it's about but the body's supposed
to be I do like that it has the armored
glass well apparently not
I really dig you though yeah everyone
thought I was gonna hate I actually
loved it hmm yeah you can order yours
now
really oh yeah what does it come it's
kind of ramp oh right my son would love
that those are the real that's pretty
young sales to be it's not for me
nothing right not for you yeah it's not
for boomers I'm not a Boomer I do all
right now not if it's 40 grand
oh nice yeah yeah I'll buy one yeah then
you trick it out nah leave it like that
yeah I think based off of when you
placed your order and when it's
confirmed they'll give you a date to
when you can receive it I'll do that for
it's very interesting that's cool
it's hilarious the windows broke yeah he
loves all this right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue oh good what's
gonna happen what are you gonna do use
some of that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]